let's talk about joe biden
joe biden's husband joe biden joe biden
is not a good president what oh come on
hold on i will not have that talk on
shim cast irl joe biden's the greatest
president we've ever had i got serious
question for you who is the last great
president oh man you can't ask me
something like that here's the thing
jimmy carter man i have oh come on bro
what are you doing shim cast irl i mean
we're gonna look at this
johnson is the next one
i think i've said this before i
definitely think trump is the best
president of my lifetime in terms of the
last great president that's a really
tough question
i i don't know i don't know eisenhower
was pretty damn good yeah i like
eisenhower i like that guy oh yeah he's
trusted him he's the one who came out
was like the military industrial complex
trump said the same thing yeah yeah
well let's talk about uh mr joe biden um
so earlier today i did a segment and it
was probably one of the easiest segments
i've ever done because i was just so
grossly offended by the media joe biden
came out i'm sorry the bind
administration saying alarm bells the
rising gas prices energy prices are
going to stifle the recovery and opec
they need to start producing more supply
so that we have cheaper gas prices and i
said hey wait a minute joe that's your
fault it is your fault gas prices are
going up exactly but what does the media
say
gop pounces
on on claims that joe biden
caused the prices to go up and then i
see every fact check after fact check it
for fact check saying false false false
false false republicans are lying
republicans are lying and then i was
like oh boy
first and foremost
the framing of all these fact checks was
joe biden shutting down keystone xl and
banning fracking on public land did not
cause prices to go up is that what
republicans said
i'm not a fan of most of these guys but
one of the things i think it was
grassley who said inflation by bad
policy is causing all prices to go up of
which one of the core basic necessities
for an average person is gas
and inflation means that gas will go up
as well now you can argue oh now you're
arguing semantics and just trying to
save face oh it goes deeper than that
i'm looking at all these fact checks my
favorite is when usa today says
gas is going up not because of biden's
policies but because of a lack of supply
demand is here but supply is short i
wonder why the whole lack of supply then
you get courts saying there is no
shortage of gasoline in this country
because they're writing about different
things and i'm like okay now we're
getting the semantics of what it means
that this is that there's a short supply
or a shortage low supply doesn't mean
shortage because low supply means it's
available but shortage means no okay
they're the same thing so you can't have
the news coming out screaming there is
no shortage of gas while they're saying
prices are going up because there's a
shortage of gas at the same time this is
what the media does and it's ridiculous
i'll tell you this joe biden is the
cause of the high gas prices for i think
what one two three
three reasons first keystone pipeline
shutting it down that pipeline was not
going to be transporting crude anytime
soon
but the banning of
fracking on federal land on public lands
and keystone caused speculators to
publicly state that they felt this would
result in a low supply in the future and
high prices so they were buying now
driving prices up which reaches the gas
pump for you the consumer then you have
inflation joe biden printing this
unemployment bonus and the eviction
moratorium is causing prices across the
board to go up including your gas and
third the labor shortage because people
are getting paid and they don't have to
work they're choosing not to work and
there's a shortage of truck drivers gas
isn't making the stations gas is going
up all of that is joe biden's fault and
i'm sick of the media playing defense
because they're too stupid either
they're too stupid to look at the big
picture or they're just covering for a
garbage administration tell us how you
really feel yeah right this
it is so insanely obvious to anybody who
just reads the news all all day that joe
biden is screwing up the economy in so
many different ways we we had this jobs
report come out and there were like 954
000 jobs it's above what we predicted
this is great everyone's clapping except
job openings went up as well to record
levels 10.1 million at the same time the
projected consumer price index was going
to be 5.3 for the year it's 5.4 it's
higher than they thought what's that
it's in it's inflation it's the cost of
goods going up from from from this month
to last year it has gone up if now
you've got shake shack announcing
they're increasing the price of their
burgers tyson says their meat's going to
be more expensive pork is up i think 39
gas is up something like 30 or so
percent all of this is because biden is
doing a miserable and miserable and
pathetic job across the board
speculators are driving it up because he
banned these things then he gives russia
the nordstrom 2 pipeline this dude is is
hurting america he is hurting the
working class and the most frustrating
thing is when you try to talk to these
young populist leftist types they don't
understand how the economy works so they
side with democratic establishments
i mean
yeah you exactly right uh
there's also the extended unemployment
which has driven up i mean driven up the
cost of labor substantially which is i
guess not inherently a bad thing i think
you know workers should get paid more
generally but i'd like to do it in a way
that isn't doesn't require us to pay
people who can go work or would should
be able to go work and pay them like you
know we're still paying extended
unemployment benefits in a world where
there's like a million times
10.1 million job openings and not enough
workers in the market to fill those jobs
and
look i i posted a video this is actually
the i think the biggest video i've ever
posted instagram because my i don't
really care about instagram all that
much i just post fun stuff
we were shopping
and we were we were going to the dairy
section looking at the milk and i saw
this little thing a little star on the
on the fridge and it said 500 hiring
bonus and i was like that's a weird
place to put the higher on the milk
section and then i look and there's
another one another one another one
another one every 10 feet was saying 500
hiring bonus yeah now we've seen those
signs and we've talked about them before
we have seen the fast food restaurant
saying well we're hired where we'll give
you payout bonus a thousand bucks come
open interviews
it's getting worse
yeah the the last week or like two weeks
ago i went grocery shopping we did not
see these bonuses the grocery store had
employees and it's gotten so bad in the
past couple of weeks now even my local
grocery store is saying we're like we're
basically desperate two questions did
you plant those
signs before you got the video no okay i
didn't think so dude that's that's but
it's got like 100 like 30 or so thousand
views on instagram and it was just me
shopping like look at this and it's got
like 1300 comments people are
recognizing this stuff in their areas
and the craziest thing to me you know
blows my mind
democrats believe the economy is fairly
good yeah yeah i mean if this is
something you mean well it's because
they live in the cities where it's like
there there was already a high minimum
wage in a lot of elite cities so the
difference effectively what the extended
unemployment did is it creates its own
very high minimum exactly it resets the
market right because it's like the
opportunity cost of going to work or
going to work right um and so in a place
of the high minimum wage already it's
not actually going to change the labor
market that much
in a place that's in the rural area
where people are getting paid close to
actual minimum wage things are
dramatically different like i was
driving down to north carolina we
stopped right
outside of richmond
we were like oh let's go to a waffle
house we walked in first thing you see
is a little like display kind of like
you know those science projects
right like those science you know the
third fourth grade science project
little panels they're being like come
work here it's so wonderful walk in
they're like sorry i want to go only
because no staff yeah then we go across
the street to the fuddruckers you can
see on the sign there it says we're only
open 12 to 8 because of staffing issues
yup like every if you're in rural
america
any restaurant it's like staffing issues
galore and it's getting worse
so we have it we have a local diner and
we went there only one section was open
and it said they they were closing early
like i think they were closing at like 6
p.m or something i posted about this i
remember the exact time they were
closing but closing early and i was like
whoa this is a diner like diners like
aren't they supposed to be open 24 7 you
come in for breakfast lunch and dinner
and then we went in and they were short
staffed and they were like we're
desperately trying to hire cooks
somebody super chatted us the other day
saying that at their ihop
they had to ship in a cook from a
different store because
i would have would have had to have
clothes because had no staff yeah
look i just want to interject you and by
the way i think you hit the nail on the
head perfectly when you said that
it's insane to be giving people massive
unemployment benefits when there are so
there's such a surplus of jobs that
people aren't taking it completely
defeats the purpose but also given what
you've just said it becomes clear to
anyone who didn't already recognize this
that our fl our framing is totally off
here because the way it stated is x new
jobs were created this month but these
aren't new jobs so to speak i mean they
are but they came in and shut down the
entire economy and now some of the jobs
that we used to have are being
reinstated though you can't even quite
say that they're being reinstated
because a lot of the small businesses
that were shut down are never going to
reopen and now these services are being
provided for by larger companies but
when we get these job numbers i mean
this is getting the economy back to
quote-unquote normal this isn't
improving our condition overall
yeah and uh it's just i mean it's it's
incredibly sad it's gonna it's gonna
change the way i mean what it's gonna do
to restaurants in this country oh yeah
especially in areas that aren't wealthy
it's gonna change it to like sweden like
in sweden and scandinavia with socialism
people don't go to restaurants very
often because they're absurdly expensive
and i think that's ultimately where
we're going we're just going to get to a
point where normal working-class people
can't go to restaurants
i'll push back a little bit the
scandinavian countries aren't socialist
they're just
welfare states yeah yeah and i think the
reason the prices are really high is
because they're like cold
you know maybe but no i mean
there are other european countries where
you can go to restaurants that's true
it's very common
so i've been to sweden norway and
denmark uh a couple different times each
and the prices are insane for whatever
reason now here's what's fascinating
because i'll agree with you on this
point when i was in bergen norway we
were i was walking down this like you
know this i can't remember where it was
like a boulevard mark a market street
kind of boulevard and there was a street
vendor with a styrofoam plate and fried
fried fish fillets and french fries fish
and chips and i was like street food you
can always count on street food wherever
you go yeah you got to enjoy that right
walk up the guy and i'm like all right
let's do uh let's do some fish and chips
he scoops that up puts it on the
styrofoam plate and says fifty dollars
yes where how much where's bergen norway
wow same in iceland d bucks 50 u.s
dollars 50 us dollars it's like the
actual boutique
he did not say that'll be 50 bucks sir
he was like you know whatever crowns or
whatever yeah and then i looked it up
and i was like that's got to be a
mistake and i showed him he was like
yeah and so i was talking to someone who
was in norway and they were like oh yeah
that's normal for us like going out to
eat is like a special thing
and i was like
i was watching a uh interview what was
in the interview putin was talking to a
bunch of students like six years ago and
they were like what should we do
premiere and he was like learn to cook
and they all laughed no really what
should we learn to do what should we do
it's like learn to cook
yeah dude and it was like shock waves
now i'm feeling the shock waves of what
he was saying we talked about we talked
about this a lot with michaela peterson
the other day people do not eat properly
they eat trash that's true and it really
does is a bad effect from the ground up
garbage in garbage out fast food
disgusting phrase what food is not
supposed to also
medicine so here's here's where i'm at
with like this this this you know
collapse we're witnessing the slow
motion collapses
i i fast food tastes good i don't like
it you know what i mean yeah sure but
you know it just because i don't like it
does it mean that we should have some
authority come in and just sledgehammer
the industries and the people that the
things that people like
this is michael bloomberg's ideology do
you remember when michael bloomberg said
tax the poor yeah i'm not exaggerating
he literally said that why he said
they're too st michael bloomberg said
that poor people are are and michael
bloomberg said too stupid
and michael bloomberg said i'm doing
this on purpose
michael bloomberg he didn't say that
what i i shouldn't have even interjected
i'm doing this on purpose i didn't say
that part no i'm saying his name several
times michael bloomberg said
that poor people according to bloomberg
are too stupid
and according to bloomberg the
government needs to spend money
according to bloomberg for them because
they wouldn't know what to buy properly
and they would buy bad things and hurt
themselves that's an indicative
mentality of this elite i don't like
saying elite because i don't think
they're doing a very good job so they're
obviously low level but they're up
they've got these positions of power and
they really think people are like cattle
they think that they can't do things for
themselves and they can't think for
themselves so they build these
institutions to take care of them
maybe they're right maybe there's
something to the wild human stupidity
and we have to corral them and and
i don't know no you're right i mean
generally speaking that is the
progressive perspective so when you hear
these lefties come out and say things
like well we need a single-payer system
because people can't just choose their
healthcare in the private market now
first of all our healthcare system has
many issues i think that there's a lot
of reform that has to take place in
order to straighten it out but the
argument that the best possible solution
for people is for their money to be
funneled through the state so the
government can make that decision for
them is exactly embodied in what
bloomberg said so even though he said
the quiet part loud i don't think it's
all that uncommon in attitude
i'm trying to find something from this
video i watched recently but i can't
find the graph here the funny thing is
they're like the biggest idiots
themselves like
they simultaneously believe that like
for example it's conservative trump
voters who are the biggest anti-vaxxed
population i don't i haven't seen the
evidence of that um that was brianna
kalar and then they also
are thinking what are we gonna do for
vaccine outreach oh i know we'll have
some gender-bending weirdo
like and by the way that guy was ripping
off the character from 30 rock the dude
just blatantly ripping that character
off you know what i'm talking about but
that doesn't matter
i mean
stands right there they're
they seem to be marketing towards a
left-wing demographic even though their
claim is that it's generally trump
supporters who need to be reached the
cia was doing that too with their
recruitment campaigns like i don't know
i think they'll be like oh well we tried
reaching out to trump supporters they
didn't buy the gender bending they
didn't like it i guess they'll just
force them to get that 20 year old tick
tocker who is gender bending it's crazy
i guess there's nothing we can do that's
funny so ian i think you're a little bit
right about people not exactly knowing
what's right for them and it's because
people aren't fully responsible and i
think this is part of what's given the
government so much power over us and
this is why we're facing rising
authoritarianism
i think we're also giving humans too
much credit like people think they're
like above the animal kingdom in a lot
of ways and it's disturbing because
we're just animals that repeat what
we're told and we believe what we're
told speak for yourself accept shameless
yeah i think i disagree i i disagree i
think
sentience goes a long way i mean we can
give credit to dolphins and elephants i
guess horse and cats and dogs i mean
they're all sentient you have you have
uh the
humans have great power very intelligent
i'm not denying that but still animals
and and we need to eat and destroy to
consume to live and we're we we make
smelly poops and we're disgusting
we've probably argued about this before
i believe we have free will and so that
place is above animals i wouldn't
consider humans animals we're creatures
were created things but i wouldn't put
us in the animal kingdom the free will
conversation is fascinating like our
i used to think that we have total free
will but now i think we're just kind of
captive to our surroundings like i can't
not eat
i would love to not eat well i don't
think you have freedom to defy the laws
of nature or physics what's stopping you
from getting up right now and just
leaving
not much well that would just do it
that's free will
my concession of reality like i would
never do that because i have a greater
goal and a plan that i feel like i'm
compelled towards you have free will you
could say that whole plan i can throw
out the window and just get up and walk
out but you you don't so it's not
because you're being forced to stay here
you have the free will to choose thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you